INTERVIEWER: This is a 2015
video of International Space
Station astronauts Scott Kelly,
Kjell Lindgren, and Kimiya Yui,
enjoying a simple salad.
Except it's not simple.
It's actually the most important
salad in human history.
Why?
Because these ISS astronauts
aren't just eating lettuce.
They're dining on
the first lettuce
to be grown and eaten in space.
And it's all thanks
to this creatively
named unit, the Vegetable
Production System,
otherwise known as Veggie.
Now trying to grow plants in
space isn't exactly a new idea.
There have been many
attempts in the past.
In 1997, bean seedlings were
grown on the Mir Space Station.
And in 2012, ISS
astronaut Don Pettit
grew a zucchini
plant for a year.
He even wrote a
blog about it called
"Diary of a Space Zucchini."
And NASA has been
looking into crop support
systems for over 30 years.
But Project Veggie is the
first large-scale effort
to produce food crops
in space, an idea that
is going to be critical
if we want astronauts
to make long duration missions
to places like Mars a reality.
GIOIA MASSA: In space, if you
can get those environmental
conditions right-- the
light, the temperature,
the atmosphere, the
nutrients, and the water--
if you can get
those right, plants
grow pretty well
and pretty similarly
as they grow on earth.
INTERVIEWER: That
was Dr. Gioia Massa,
who leads the Veggie team
at the Kennedy Space Center,
the group responsible for
tackling the challenges
of growing plants in space.
So far, the biggest of which
has been coming up with a way
to water plants in a
microgravity environment.
GIOIA MASSA: You don't
think about how difficult it
is to water in microgravity,
or to wash your vegetables
or things like that,
until you start
to watch some of these videos
of just how water behaves
in space.
INTERVIEWER: In order to tackle
the problem of providing water,
nutrients, and light to plants
within a space environment,
the Kennedy Space
Center teamed up
with Orbital
Technologies Corporation
to design and build
the Veggie unit.
The hardware uses a
passive watering system
supported by plant pillows.
These pillows are
single-use pockets
filled with soil substrate and
control released fertilizer.
Embedded into the pillow is
a moisture wicking material
where seeds can be
glued and carefully
orientated to ensure
that the roots grow down
and the shoots grow up.
The LED light bank provides
red, blue, and green light
to help plants generate energy.
And the walls of
the whole system
can be extended upward,
allowing room for growth.
It was this low
mass modular system
that was sent to
the ISIS in 2014,
where an astronaut set the unit
up and started to grow lettuce
as a test species.
The crew also grew
zinnia flowers
to test the long-term
survival of flowering crops,
like tomatoes.
Initially, it was a success.
The first group of
lettuce grown in Veggie
was sent back to
Earth for analysis.
After those samples
were deemed edible,
the ISS astronauts were
given the green light
to tuck into the second
crop of leafy greens, which
of course, they did.
The zinnias, however,
were a different story.
Shortly after nurturing
this bright orange flower,
Scott Kelly sent this
tweet from the ISS.
"Our plants aren't
looking too good.
Would be a problem on Mars.
I'm going to have to channel
my inner Mark Watney."
Despite channeling Mark Watney,
Scott's flowering zinnias
were dying, and there was
nothing he could do about it.
GIOIA MASSA: We did get
fungus growing on the zinnia.
And we were kind of
estimating water volumes
for the astronauts to
give to the plants.
And our estimates
were not right.
And so there was excess
water in the plant chamber.
And this led to fungus.
INTERVIEWER: Now
you'll be relieved
to know that Scott did manage
to save some of his zinnias.
And the moldy ones?
They were sent back
to Massa's team
at the Kennedy Space Center, who
eagerly started analyzing them.
GIOIA MASSA: We've been
doing a lot of research
here on the tissue
that was brought back,
to try and understand
where this fungus came from
and how it infected
these plants,
so that we will
learn for the future.
INTERVIEWER: So far,
five Veggie crops
have been harvested on the ISS.
And each time, the
team have learned
how to tweak the hardware to
support healthy space produce.
And aside from fine tuning
Veggie to optimize plant health
and growth, the team
are also experimenting
with different levels
and intensities
of red, blue, and
green LED light
to make space crops more
nutritious and delicious.
Now chlorophyll, the pigment
involved in generating plant
energy via photosynthesis,
absorbs red and blue light
best.
Essentially, these
wavelengths help space crops
to grow without sunlight.
Recent studies have also shown
a small amount of green light
could be important for
dense plant growth,
particularly in poor light
conditions like in deep space.
However, getting the
light balance just right
is still a work in progress.
GIOIA MASSA: It's
a really fun puzzle
to figure out, what
different plants are doing.
You might get higher
levels of certain vitamins
under blue light.
Red light tends to make
leafy crops expand more.
But it's not, it's
not a universal thing.
For the most part,
these light experiments
seem to be yielding
delicious results.
In early 2017, astronauts Peggy
Whitson and Shane Kimbrough
grew a Chinese
cabbage on the ISS.
And it was considered the best
tasting veggie crop so far.
It was a proud moment
for those astronauts.
And that speaks to
another strength
of Project Veggie, its
ability to boost morale
among those stationed on the
ISS for long periods of time.
GIOIA MASSA: It's just been
incredible to watch them work
and to watch them
grow the plants.
We're actually very interested
in the human factors
and the psychological
aspects of this.
And so that's one
of the components
of the Veg-04 and
Veg-05 experiment
will be to do some
assessments trying
to quantify how much
the plants might
impact the experience
of living in space.
INTERVIEWER: Next
year, NASA is set
to launch the Advanced Plant
Habitat, the largest plant
chamber built so far.
The APH shares similar
technology to Veggie,
but will be able to
hold larger crops.
So who knows?
Perhaps the idea of astronauts
growing potatoes on Mars
might not seem so far
fetched after all.
NASA may have plans
to make Mars habitable
using a giant space magnet.
To find out more,
watch this episode now.
Thanks for watching, and
don't forget to subscribe.